peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le conseil constitutionnel a tranché le
pass sanitaire a été validé pour les
cafés et restaurants ainsi que
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants est
la loi a été promulguée aujourd'hui et
qu'abriel attal confirme qu'une semaine
de rodage sera toléré selon lui le
gouvernement a conscience des
difficultés d'organisation que le passé
de terre peut poser après cette annonce
un appel à la mobilisation a été lancée
dès demain dans 150 villes françaises en
italie aussi il ya un sanitaire les
italiens l'appelle le green face et son
application est légèrement différente en
france puisqu'il sera obligatoire pour
les enseignants ceux qui n ont pas
pendant cinq jours d'affilée seront
suspendus et leur salaire sera gelé
[Musique]
offensive talibane poursuite et
intensification les insurgés s'empare
d'eux arrange capitale provinciale
il revendique l'assassinât d'un haut
responsable à kaboul
leur avancée inquiète réunion d'urgence
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur arte
france il est 20 heures
c'est désormais officiel le pass
sanitaire sera étendu dès lundi aux
restaurants et cafés jusqu en terrasse
les soignants seront dans l'obligation
de se faire vacciner sous peine de
sanctions le conseil constitutionnel a
validé ces dispositions de la loi
sanitaire et un à censurer certaines lé
détail avec nicolas pepsi c'était l'une
des mesures les plus emblématiques du
pass sanitaires les cafés et restaurants
seront bien soumis au contrôle
le conseil constitutionnel a estimé que
ces nouvelles mesures étaient justifiées
et répondait à une conciliation
équilibrée entre les exigences de
protection de la santé et des libertés
individuelles
outre l'accès à certains centres
commerciaux
l'extension du pass sanitaire concernera
aussi les visiteurs et patients non
urgents des établissements de santé et
maisons de retraite
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants et les autres professions en
contact avec des publics fragiles a
également reçu l'approbation des sages
une position saluée par jean castex le
conseil constitutionnel a validé
l'essentiel des dispositions de la loi
relative à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
elle permettra le plein déploiement de
notre stratégie de lutte contre la copie
19 tel que présenté par le président de
la république le 12 juillet dernier
seuls deux mesures prévues initialement
ont été retoqués par le conseil
constitutionnel
l'isolément obligatoire de 10 jours des
personnes diagnostiquées positive au co
vide et juger ni nécessaire ni adaptée
ni proportionnée et constitue une mesure
privative de liberté
en l'absence de passe le salaire pourra
être suspendu mais le licenciement des
salariés en cdd ou en intérim avant le
terme du contrat a été censuré pas de
quoi se réjouir au sein de l'opposition
qui a très largement commenté ces
décisions des hautes instances
très décevant décision du conseil
constitutionnel
ils ne protègent aucune des libertés
menacées par le patient ni terre humour
noir un cdd ne peut être interrompue
mais son salaire reste suspendue le
conseil constitutionnel censure l'
isolement obligatoire et le licenciement
des salariés en cdd qui ne présenterai
pas de passes annie terre des garde-fous
nécessaires mais le pass and i ter ne
suffira pas à stopper l'épidémie
la vaccination obligatoire reste la
meilleure solution le conseil
constitutionnel se vautre dans
l'indignité en validant quasiment tout
comme prévu il trahi la constitution la
france et le peuple de france
élan vital présence massive pour la
manif du 7 août
malgré un pass sanitaires ont entériné
florian philippot ne compte pas en
rester là
après plusieurs week-ends de forte
affluence le chef de file des
manifestations anti passe appelle à
nouveau au rassemblement ce samedi à
paris selon thierry amouroux porte
parole du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers est le conseil
des sages n'a pas pris en compte les
conseils de l'ordre des médecins
concernant l'extension du pass
sanitaires à l'hôpital écoutez le bien
ça veut dire que les lissages ne sont
pas tant que ça
conseil de l'ordre des médecins avait
alerté sur les problèmes d'accès aux
soins liés à se passer ni terre le
conseil constitutionnel ne l'a pas
entendu et ça pose un vrai problème en
termes bien de perte de chance d des
patients avec eux à un retard au
diagnostic ou au traitement par rapport
aux personnes qui n'auraient pas leur
pass sanitaires et qui serait le patient
en soins chroniques ou nouveaux patients
en consultation et ça c'est un vrai
souci pour nous et en italie il s'agit
d'une green pass l'équivalent du passani
terre il est obligatoire dès aujourd'hui
pour aller à la piscine au cinéma entre
autres est la différence avec notre pas
sanitaires il est obligatoire pour les
enseignants et ceux qui refusent seront
suspendus
nous sommes engagés à faire de notre
mieux pour ouvrir les écoles en toute
sécurité en septembre et en présentiel
avec cette nouvelle loi
nous ordonnons à passe vers obligatoire
pour accéder aux écoles pour tous les
employés des écoles l'arrêté approuvé
par le conseil des ministres introduit
le pass vert dans les transports publics
pas dans tous des principalement ceux de
longues distances
en particulier il sera obligatoire de
présenter le pass vert pour accéder aux
navires utilisés pour les services de
transport commercial et de passagers
cela concerne aussi les vols les navires
et les ferries utilisé pour les
déplacements sur les lignes
interrégionales et pour mateo gil
alberti journaliste a field media.com le
gouvernement italien a tendance
infantiliser la population écoutez le
les italiens eux aussi sont plutôt
critique surtout pour l'attitude
infantilisant et bien utilisé par le
gouvernement italien et la
stigmatisation qui a été introduite un
peu comme c'était le cas en france avec
des discours commun celui du
porte-parole du gouvernement un gabriel
attal ou même du président de la
république emmanuel mâcon en italie
aussi vieilli cette espèce de
condescendance vis-à-vis des citoyen qui
en fait pour la plupart des cas
d'ailleurs sont vaccinés comme aimait ma
principale d'avoir cette imposition
cette restriction de la liberté
d'ailleurs il faut aussi dire que il y a
beaucoup de citoyens italiens qui
souhaiteraient se faire vacciner mais
qui ne trouvent pas de rente de gauche
en tunisie la crise du coc vide a eu des
conséquences et pas des moindres après
le limogeage du premier ministre suite à
une mauvaise gestion de l'épidémie entre
autres à l'opposition n'a pas hésité à
qualifier cette décision de coup d'état
constitutionnel
mais il en faudra plus pour faire
reculer le chef de l'état déterminé elle
la tunisie traverse une crise politique
majeure alors que la population attend
toujours la nomination d'un
vos gouvernements lé précision notre
correspondant bassam chili à tunis pas
de marche arrière le ton est ferme le
message clair celui adressé par le
président de la tunisie à ses opposants
lors d'une courte vidéo publiée hier par
les services de la présidence de
carthage après le limogeage du premier
ministre et le gel du parlement tunisien
le 25 juillet dernier
taye sayed poursuit sa feuille de route
vent debout dans l'oeil de l'homme fort
de la tunisie ennahda le parti islamiste
qui avait condamné la décision
présidentielle en la qualifiant de coup
d'état constitutionnel semble revenir
sur ses pas réunis mercredi en session
extraordinaire à la première force
politique du pays
plus que jamais déstabilisé par une
crise en interne et un rejet par une
partie de la population a appelé par la
voix de son chef de file rached
ghannouchi à l'apaisement et à
l'ouverture au dialogue nécessaire pour
avancer dans la voie démocratique
un message qui n'a pas trouvé écho
auprès du président de la république en
réponse kyle sayyed a déclaré qu'il n'y
aura pas de dialogue sauf avec les gens
honnêtes excluant toute discussion avec
ceux qui l' a qualifié de cellules
cancéreuses depuis son coup de force qui
a et ça y est tu n'as toujours pas nommé
de nouveau premier ministre ni annoncer
de mesures pour sortir de l'état
d'urgence laissant planer le doute sur
ses intentions alors qu'ils les
tunisiens attendent toujours les
réformes nécessaires au sauvetage du
pays
la direction le moyen-orient et ce
regain de tension entre l'île le liban
et israël
l armée israélienne mène des frappes
vers le sud du liban en riposte à des
tirs de roquettes revendiquer et par le
hezbollah et les dernières frappes
aériennes
un alien contre le territoire libanais
avaient lieu près de la frontière avec
la syrie mais en 2014
le porte-parole militaire de l'armée
israélienne ne veut pas d' escalade mais
dit se tenir prêt est la mission
onusienne au liban appelle à un cessez
le feu immédiat en afghanistan
l'offensive talibane s'intensifient les
insurgés s'empare d'eux arrange une
ville de province après avoir appris le
contrôle de territoires ruraux les
talibans se rapproche des grandes villes
il revendique par ailleurs l'assassinât
du chef du service de communication hac
du gouvernement à kaboul
une situation qui inquiète également les
dirigeants des ex républiques
soviétiques d'asie centrale
cinq pays se sont réunis au turkménistan
une réunion du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu a eu lieu aujourd'hui
écoutez à ce propos l'ambassadeur afghan
aux nations unies on a été obligé de
demander cette réunion urgente car la
situation en afghanistan s'est
rapidement détériorée en raison de la
récente escalade de la violence des
talibans et de l'offensive militaire
brutale sur les grandes villes et les
centres de population de plusieurs
provinces
nous demandons conseille d'utiliser les
outils existants y compris la mise en
oeuvre effective du régime de sanctions
et la résolution 1988 et la résolution
2000 513 du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
pour faire pression sur les talibans
pour qu'ils s'engagent dans des
pourparlers de paix significative avec
l'équipe de négociation du gouvernement
écoutez l'analyse de riadh sidaoui
directeur du centre arabe de recherches
d'analystes politiques et sociales c'est
toujours on distingue entre l'onu le
secrétariat et oui le conseil de
sécurité il faut une résolution des
conceptions acquis de ce conseil de
sécurité qu'il passe par le chapitre 7
de la charte de l'onu donc une
mobilisation encore des forces mondiales
afin de arrêté il était contre les
talibans et les forces de l'otan n'ont
pas réussi déjà à déstabiliser le talent
est bon je pense et américaines sont au
vert des cordes et des compromis avec le
taliban donc cette fois ci à mon avis il
n'y aura pas d intervention massive de
l'étranger parce que la question d'al
qaïda n'existe plus
la prison de guantanamo où va-t-elle
enfants fermé ses portes des
parlementaires démocrates pressent le
président américain de mettre un terme à
cette prison est très régulièrement
critiqué pour ses nombreux manquements
en matière de droits de l'homme
mais le dossier est compliqué
politiquement et d'autre avant joe biden
avait tenté mais peine perdue jusqu'à
présent pour en parler on retrouve notre
correspondant à washington thomas boni
thomas bonjour alors concrètement que
demandent ces élus démocrates au
président joe biden
ils sont 75 élus plutôt de l'ailé gauche
du parti démocrate a signé co signé
cette lettre ouverte en verre destiné à
joe biden pour faire pression sur le
président américain pour fermer cette
prison de guantanamo il fixe trois
priorités d'abord réduire le nombre de
détenus à l'intérieur de la prison
ensuite à traiter ces détenus de manière
plus humaine et enfin rendre les
procédures plus transparentes l'objectif
final évidemment c'est donc de fermer
définitivement cette prison de
guantanamo il utilise pour cela des
arguments moraux évidemment mais aussi
des arguments financiers écouter selon
des informations de presse la prison
coût de plus de 500 millions de dollars
par an soit un coût annuel exorbitant de
13 millions de dollars par prisonnier le
fait que la prison soit encore ouverte
et une tache sur notre réputation
internationale et mine notre capacité à
défendre les droits humains et l'état de
droit est d'accord sur le principe de
fermer cette prison de guantanamo mais
il est prudent parce qu'il était aux
premières loges lorsque près barack
obama en 2009 avait fait cette promesse
de fermer la prison de guantanamo
pendant la première année de son mandat
on se rappelle qu'à l'époque il en avait
été empêché par un blocage parlementaire
du congrès alors à la place ils à
diminuer petit à petit le nombre de
détenus dans cette prison de guantanamo
un processus qui a été arrêté ensuite
par donald trump on n'est quand même pas
assez de 800 détenus à 40 prisonniers
aujourd'hui détenu dans cette prison de
guantanamo alors que je m'adonne
voudrait fermer cette prison d'ici la
fin de son mandat il fait plutôt profil
bas il est plutôt discret ne veut pas
faire de ce sujet un sujet polémique et
qu'ils soient exposées dans les médias
parce qu'il sait qu'il y aura face à lui
une forte opposition de la part
notamment d'un certain nombre d'élus
républicains
on rappelle que cette prison de
guantanamo a été ouverte en 2002 sous la
présidence de george w bush c'était
quelques mois seulement après les
attentats du 11 septembre une prison qui
est très régulièrement pointée du doigt
par des organisations pour les
manquements aux droits de l'homme et
pour les conditions de vie indignes qui
sont donc à l'intérieur de cette prison
alors ce qui pourrait se passer ces
prochains mois d'abord ce sont des
transferts d'un certain nombre de
détenus c'est ce qu'avait annoncé la
porte parole de la maison blanche
il y a quelques semaines mais ces
procédures sont rendues compliquées par
ce qu'il faut comprendre qu'une grande
partie à des prisonniers actuellement à
guantanamo n'ont pas encore été jugés
il ya par exemple un certain nombre d'
accusé d'avoir participé aux attentats
du 11 septembre 2001 ils n'ont toujours
pas été condamnée ni donc juger par les
cours militaires américaines et cela
complique évidemment les transferts qui
devrait quand même avoir lieu pour
certains d'entre eux disent et des
prochains mois merci thomas bonnet pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes en direct de washington
dans un courrier adressé à la famille du
livreur gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur explique
qu'il n'existe pas de preuve pouvant
justifier la suspension des policiers
mis en cause dans le décès de cédric
chou via malgré les premiers éléments
d'une enquête accablant pour les
fonctionnaires les précisions de david
khalifa justice politique police des
éléments constitutifs d'une république
démocratique et juste quand les pouvoirs
sont séparés et correctement exercés
mais quand ceci converge on court le
risque de voir apparaître une justice
politique où la volonté du pouvoir tant
à utiliser les procédures judiciaires à
des fins politiques
une définition qui pourrait s'appliquer
à la situation actuelle à du dossier
chou vient bref rappel des faits le 3
janvier
2020 cédric joue via est victime d'un
malaise cardiaque
aux abords de la tour eiffel après avoir
été plaqué au sol
casque sur la tête par trois policiers
au terme d'un contrôle routier tendu
deux jours plus tard il meurt d'une
asphyxie avec fracture du larynx en
juillet 2020 l enquête a conduit les
juges d'instruction à mettre en examen
et placé sous contrôle judiciaire pour
homicide involontaire trois des quatre
fonctionnaires impliqués dans ce
contrôle routier qui a dégénéré
les avocats de la famille ont par
ailleurs réclamé la suspension de ces
policiers en décembre dernier demande
qui s'est vu adresser une fin de non
recevoir de la part du ministre de
l'intérieur
dans un courrier adressé à la famille le
21 juin dernier les premiers éléments de
l'enquète n'ont pu permettre d'établir
que les fonctionnaires avaient commis
lors de l'interpellation de monsieur
chevaux via un manquement à leurs
obligations tel qui soit susceptible de
justifier d'une mise à l'écart de leurs
services ainsi pour gérald darmanin la
mort d'un homme ne justifie pas la mise
à l'écart d'un fonctionnaire de police
dont la responsabilité est
potentiellement engager une prise de
position qui pose question dans la
sphère éclair à du nom de ce producteur
tabassé par des policiers en novembre
le ministre de l'intérieur avait jugé
qu'il était de son devoir de suspendre
les policiers mis en cause la famille se
souvient ne comprends pas cette
différence de traitement
en effet sur ces images on peut voir
clairement les policiers exerçant une
pression sur cédric joue via plaqué au
sol et alors qu'ils savent fixe y est
sous le poids des policiers il avait
alerté à plus de sept reprises en leur
criant j'étouffe et ce n'est pas tout
l'igpn
dans une note du 17 juin 2020 relate un
autre point concernant la technique
d'appréhension mise en oeuvre par les
policiers alors que trois des quatre
policiers ont poursuivi leur pression
sur son dos l'un d'entre eux semblé lui
pratiquer un étranglement arrière à
l'occasion duquel il avait au moins une
fois exercer une traction sur sa gorge
conduisant à une compromission
momentanée de l'axé tête coûteront la
fameuse clé d'étranglement dans
christophe castaner avait annoncé
l'abandon il ya un an et qui vient
d'être remplacé par des techniques
issues du judo principalement
responsable dans cette affaire on en
croit le compte rendu de légers
pn quoi qu'il en soit cette décision de
gérald darmanin semble incompréhensible
le ministre de l'intérieur se justifie
d'une autre manière pour éviter une
suspension est d'après lui les
fonctionnaires n'auraient jamais été
impliqué dans des faits de violences
illégitimes durant leur carrière
affirmation fausse le principal
policiers mis en cause michael p a fait
l'objet d'un signalement auprès de
l'igpn conduisant à une enquête
judiciaire pour violences en avril 2018
les avocats de la famille de cédric joue
via dénonce une culture du lait cette
fin de non-recevoir ne peut s'analyser
autrement que comme la négation de la
réalité de cette affaire et des
aspirations de la famille elle résonne
comme un cruel dédain à l'égard de ceux
ayant perdu un père un mari un fils un
frère une suspension ne ramènera pas
monsieur cédric joue via mais à linverse
son absence rend son décès encore plus
inexplicable et intolérable la famille
souvient fais confiance à la justice
mais pour combien de temps encore et la
question est pour en parler nous sommes
nous avec christian chou via le père de
cédric souvient christophe souvient
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france alors on l'a
vu trois policiers sont mis en examen
pour homicide involontaire une quatrième
fonctionnaires est placé sous le statut
de témoin assisté
malgré les soupçons très graves qui
pèsent sur eux le ministère de
l'intérieur estime que les suspendre de
leurs fonctions
elle n'est pas justifiée quelle est
votre réaction c'est toujours le le fait
que monsieur darmanin est en train de
délivrer des permis de tuer je crois que
aujourd'hui on peut tu quand on est de
la police on peut tuer librement on
après on a pas de recours
darmanin couvre tout l'allemand le
préfet de police de paris couvre tous à
tous couverts au début de la faire et
aujourd'hui on continue avec le couvert
de notre président de la république
puisqu'il espère tout ça depuis plus de
18 mois et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans un scandale de liberté d
de liberté de tous c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes dans la rue ou
vos contrôles on vous tue qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour cédric confie cédric on
va contrôler on l'a tué soit aucun motif
le 21 juillet 2021 l'igpn qui est la
police des polices relève des
contradictions dans le récit des
policiers puis ils sont mis en examen
pour homicide involontaire
le ministère de l'intérieur le ministre
de l'intérieur pardon darmana reste
fidèle aux policiers vraisemblablement à
moins d'un an des présidentielles
pourquoi selon vous parce que il a une
position ferme et définitive c'est qu'il
veut couvrir tous ses policiers
les bons comme les mauvais surtout les
mauvais qui sont là en fin de compte
avec un père me tuer je le répète je dis
la position d'armes assez ils achètent
ils achètent ces gens pour que s'il ya
débat
c'est pas des bavures c'est si l
intention de tuer il ya des moments il
ya une intention de tuer alors que ce
soit un contrôle de police banal où que
ce soit comment une arrestation violente
parce qu'il ya des violences lui une
fille fait pas de détails
l'affairé est claire je suis désolé on
voit trois policiers fracasser des fonds
c'est un gars là on les a mis en prison
pendant quinze jours on les aperçoit
retire pour noël
pour quelle aisance presque alors papa
pour les fêtes de noël c'est un scandale
c'est un scandale dit c'est dit c'est
une bavure
il faut que j'essaye mais les caméras
ont filmé pareil l'assassinât de mon
fils il a été filmé dans les mêmes
conditions
y aller les caméras extérieures commande
publique est allé les témoins les vidéos
il ya des témoignages comme quoi que on
a entendu le son de sa voix
alors quand monsieur darmana se permet
de dire quand monsieur d'arman se permet
de dire lui quand j'entends les
violences policières
j'étouffe si ça c'est pas une si vous
voulez pas prendre ça comme un coup de
poignard pour la famille shaw bien on a
tous ressenti comme un coup de poignard
c'était peser calculer son mot il était
pesé calculer est-ce que je pense que
monsieur darmanin n'est pas n'est pas
inquiet je pense que c'est une personne
intelligente et ce qui fait ce qu'il dit
il le pèze christian julien justement
pour vous utilisez des mots très forts
vous parlez de permis de tuer la police
nationale à officialiser le remplacement
est de la technique de clé
d'étranglement par trois nouvelles
pratiques et c'est cette technique
d'intérêt
la sonde qui est mise en cause dans le
décès de votre fils est ce que c'est une
bonne chose selon vous est ce que ça
peut arranger les futurs interpellation
d'appuyer d'étranglement c'est une bonne
chose pour arrêter le placage rentable
parce que quand vous avez 200 kg 250
kilos sur le dos vous pouvais plus
respirer ce que je voulais vous dire
aussi c'est que cédric n'est pas mort
d'un malaise cardiaque
il est mort étouffé on l'a étouffé on a
tué il est pas mort d'un malaise vers
moi c'était j'étouffe et ses derniers
mots ça a été j'ai tout cette fois avant
qu'on se réveille et alors le code est
commis c'est que la seule personne qui
est témoin assisté diano j'ai rien vu
mais alors avec ténacité quoi est elle
partie elle est comme les autres la
halle à leur âge où elle est comme les
autres michael perez l'assassin moi je
pèse mais bon moi je sais qui je
m'adresse tous les deux c'est 260
christian souvient d'autres d'autres
sombres affaires sont malheureusement
similaire à celle de votre fils et à la
marde adama traoré l'agression de michel
est clair vous en avait parlé il y en a
plusieurs autres
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui
permettrait à votre à votre famille de
tenir aujourd'hui même si la blessure
est l'état vie qu'est ce qui vous donne
la force de tenir vous et votre famille
c'est la justice aujourd'hui la justice
fait un travail énorme
nous on a les comptes rendus par les
avocats tout ça ils font un travail
énorme
ils veulent la vérité la justice veut la
vérité elle fait tout pour la retrouver
elle va la trouver
je pense qu'elle va la trouver
maintenant le jugement on attend ça avec
impatience à sera peut-être dans deux
ans dans trois ans on sait pas mais
quand il aura jugement nathan sac un
passant mais aujourd'hui je peux dire
une chose c'est que dans tous les to les
policiers ne sont pas des michael perez
faut pas rêver on n'a jamais pensé ça me
dit ça met dedans quand on a des fruits
pourris faut les mettre au rancart tout
de suite faut les mettre au rancart tout
de suite et je pèse mes mots parce que
c'est des gens ils sont cédés à sas en
puissance
la preuve il avait déjà une affaire
similaire avant hélas la deuxième bombe
office il a il n'a pas tenu le choc et
il en est mort fracture du larynx
étouffement et 200 kg de guerre sur le
paletot il pouvait pas s'en sortir c'est
impossible qu'il s'en sort
c'était impossible vous pouvez demander
à tous les grands sportifs de judo de
karaté on apporte de quoi il vaut des
rendra situation était c'est impossible
donc il l'a fait sciemment il a continué
sciemment
à faire ce qu'il voulait faire parce
qu'il savait qu'il avait un couvert il
est barman a été là il est en fait au
départ d'arras
le ciom kaka qui a bien répondu à
présent ses castes arrière castaldi
j'enlèverai la clé d'étranglement
il l'a enlevée ont ils il a eu tous les
syndicats dans son bureau
ça a fait bouger on a remis la clé
d'étranglement tout de suite ça a duré
48 heures où je crois trois jours on a
remis la clé trois lances étaient tous
les syndicats sont manifestés on nous
enlève nos outils de travail
rendez compte on nous enlève nos outils
de travail qu il ya mort d'homme on
parle d' outil de travail quand il ya
mort d'homme d'accord et darmanin et
revenir si vous si vous pouviez
rapidement adressé en moa gérald
darmanin pour finir cette interview
lucie darm amincie darmanin faites votre
travail
quand vous avez des fruits pourris dans
votre saladier ont levé les mettez les à
pied et touche pour vous demande vous
demande pas grand chose et on y re
jugement paisiblement
vous comprenez monsieur darmanin c'est
tout ce que je peux vous dire je vis si
j'étais un homme je vous remercie
je vous remercie infiniment pour pour
cette interview et bon courage à vous
dans cette épreuve difficile avec votre
famille merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur arte france et c'est la
fin de cette édition merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi prochain point de
l'actualité dans 30 minutes en attendant
restez avec nous sur arte france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]